I would like to make a distinction in
say between eight zero to about fifteen
or sixteen years before I was before I
came in touch with a woman called we
called sisters either in my secondary
school in Kenya and the time after that
before I met sister
Aziza the Islam of my family was not
political so I don't I do not remember
either my father or my mother saying
that a society has to be as you know
Sharia should be the rule of of a
country or a society with one exception
in the one year that we were in Saudi
Arabia there was no distinction between
him a secular sphere and and and you
know let's see the film of syriza in the
real wolf of God these were intertwined
in Islam and in the one year that we
were in Saudi Arabia
we lived according to Sharia and the
state was ran through Islamic law
so the beheadings for instance
amputations every Friday the stonings
that kind of thing that happened and
there was a distinction when atrocities
in Somalia were carried out by a secular
dictatorship that has such as Mohamed
Siad Barre my mother would denounce
condemn those atrocities but when
atrocities were carried out in the state
of Saudi Arabia thieves were amputated
people's heads were cut off that was
Sharia law and that was something that
the victim deserved because he violated
the law of God but we left that behind
us in when we left Saudi Arabia and went
into Ethiopia
my life in Ethiopian in Kenya until my
16th year was I would just say you know
praying five
today it was very Islam was there
socially and culturally it wasn't a
political issue when I meet in 1985
sistahs is a different kind of Islam is
introduced and different meaning also
from the one I knew from my family it
was a political Islam it was very clear
it was an individual choice it was about
what she referred to as the inner she
had struggling to simply to meet the
obligations to make sure that you pray
five times instead of three times or two
times and fast all of the Ramadan days
all 30 of them not half a day as I used
to do or a week in a month or something
like that so just adhering to the rules
every day the rules halal that are
permitted and trying to abstain from
what her arm or what is forbidden this
is reinforced within the Somali
community because Kenya is a very
multicultural place and sisters it was
not a Somali but in the Somali space
there were figures like this man we call
bubble or song he who fasts for a
hundred days and he introduced the same
kind of radical political all-consuming
Islam that divides the world into we and
they and the division started within the
Islamic community so we were those of us
who followed the fruits physically those
other Muslims who are neglectful of the
rules were considered to be non-muslims
hypocrites we had all sorts of negative
attributes for them and then that they
extended to the non-muslims my
grandmother represented what we
generally generally would call
traditional nomadic Somali life and the
values of that tradition mainly tribal
very much we oriented clan oriented she
taught me my bloodline because that is
you you know you cannot survive without
your bloodline she taught us all these
anecdotes about how to survive in the
desert which animals to fear which
animals not to fear which animals to
hunt and eat and she was very
superstitious when I got ill or my
sister got ill she had no access or
knowledge of modern medicine
so she dealt with the challenges in life
with diseases with the drought and she
had superstitious explanations for it
she was a Muslim but a very different
Muslim than for instance scissor sisters
Issa how Islam was very much diluted
with her own cultural traditional
superstitions for instance she thought
it was a good thing to celebrate the
birthday of the Prophet Muhammad which
later our sisters assemble some would
say that was a bad thing to do she could
not read the Quran
she had learned a few verses by heart
just enough to pray but she didn't allow
us to put the Quran on the ground she
would make us kiss the Quran and put it
on a higher surface in first cleaner
hands before we touched it or anything
like that so she was just a more of a
traditional Somali nomadic value system
with respect to Islam we should make a
distinction between Muslims and Islam
Muslims as individual human beings like
you and me can be influenced were not
born it's not a genetic discrepancy to
be a Muslim you are just an individual
human being and you can be persuaded to
change your mind
and so engage in critical thinking and
change the course of your life Islam
just like Nazis in today is a very
violent totalitarian they dangerous
doctrine and the sooner we see it the
better
it depends on where they are if you're
in Europe or in America you have access
to so much education so much empirical
evidence that you can change your own
life if you do certain things I would
say to Muslims living in the West
take advantage free advantage of that
develop your mind and your faculties of
critical thinking and look around you
and why are we here
I mean try and answer that question why
are millions of Muslims leaving their
own home countries and seeking a better
life in the West what is it in the West
that they are doing right that we are
doing wrong if you are in Muslim
countries then there is a difference
that the wealth of Muslim countries
through oil the solely citizens the
United Arab Emirates qualities and so on
who can afford because they don't have
to go about they didn't have to spend
90% of their time seeking bread like the
poor neighborhoods of Egypt that group
can make a change and can bring in
because we live in the age of internet
and so on
they can't translate progressive books
the Enlightenment you know for my lots
of ideas books here into Arabic and
bring it and give it to their own people
right now they are only reading the
Quran it's it's very little to live on
intellectually for in poorer countries
what you see now is that the Islamic
Brotherhood or Brotherhood organizations
fundamentalist Islamic organizations
other ones who are providing the care
and it's an uncorrupted care health care
you know food the rule of law making
sure that places are safe neighborhoods
are safe and so on and that can be
challenged by I would say people who
will not replace one form of oppression
with another form of oppression